what is your strategy to win the
government my strategy to win big
brother canada is
i'm gonna be a very social person i'm
gonna be a comp piece i'm gonna win
every competition and i'm just gonna
learn uh i'm just gonna use what i
learned by watching the past season and
being a big brother a super fan what
type of personality will you clash with
in the house i will clash with the type
of personality that's that's fake
whenever i watch past seasons a lot of
time when somebody's going outside the
door they turn around say love you hey
like sometimes i don't even say that to
my wife so i'm not going to say it to
the other house guests i guarantee you
great uh showmance or no man
no man's for sure and married happily
married to the most wonderful woman on
earth
but hopefully i get a bromance why is
kenny gonna ruin you this season
canada's gonna rule for me because
they're gonna love me i'm a fun guy i
like to play praying i like to have fun
and i think canada will love me
you